of the Labour Party and the future Prime
Minister Jeremy Corbyn it's as much
about the state of British politics that
the opposition can be riven with in
fighting but still say it's winning
because the government is in an even
bigger hole like everywhere else the
decision of the Supreme Court took
everyone here by surprise and the Labour
leader Jeremy Corbyn moved his speech
forward by a day so he could get back to
Parliament's when it resumes on
Wednesday and how he enjoyed sticking
the boot in to Boris Johnson the
government will be held to account for
what it has done Boris Johnson has been
found to have misled the country this
unelected prime minister should now
resign there may be a huge rift inside
the Labour Party about his position on
brexit but it says nothing compared to
their hatred of the prime minister it'll
suddenly made Corbin's job very easy
labour will end the brexit crisis by
taking a decision back to the people
with the choice a credible leave
alongside remain that's not complicated
labour is a democratic party that people
even before Corbin spoke the talk was
whether all the opposition parties would
try to force Johnson to resign in the
confidence vote the view here was that
they needed to wait until a No Deal
brexit at the end of October had been
ruled out Boris Johnson will sign that
letter the letters even been drafted in
the legislation and applies for the
extension go forward to win an election
for the people of this country
Corbin says he and his party are ready
for that election even though the
polling suggests they would lose unless
brexit is delayed yet again but with the
government's ship sinking it's all about
the timing Labour's problem remains
jeremy corbyn's deep personal
unpopularity with voters and yet they're
up against the prime minister now
accused of breaking the law and who runs
a minority governments in a total mess
and so despite everything labor is once
again in attack mode as they head back
to Parliament in London all the
opposition parties can smell Johnson's
blood in the water their task now is to
dig up a way of working together to kill
him off
Lawrence Lee al-jazeera of the Labour
Party conference in Brighton